you say
nip uh you you got out of jail and nip
put you on a beat
as soon as you got out soon i came on
so give us a little background on your
relationship with nip how y'all
how you guys originally linked up and
obviously for you to get out of jail and
then i'm automatically
you know be tapped in with the with the
homie like like give us some
give us a little background on that man
hell yeah i mean [ __ ] when i got out of
jail and [ __ ] man bro came and picked me
up you know what i'm saying from jail he
like bro man we could
we could do whatever will you was this
well chip
well yeah wasn't it like he didn't i've
been in jail so many times
he's like every time i've been to the
jail year we talking about right now
2013 when i finally got my [ __ ] together
okay i came home
january 2013 with a plan
with a plan not to go back and just get
it right
stay in the studio you feel me so when
bro ask me what i want to do
he said i want to go [ __ ] up some hoes
[ __ ]
we go get on the helicopter we go do
whatever you feel i'm saying i'm like
bro
take me straight to the studio wow you
know what i'm saying and we went
straight to the studio
that's crazy cracking he threw me on the
beat we got cracking and they're gonna
get right